voilà Jean-Philippe Tanguy deux semaines
pour débattre de la réforme 20 jours
très exactement et plus de 20 000
amendements déposés sur le texte est-ce
que pour vous la gauche puisque
peut-être deux tiers sont déposés par la
France insoumise est-ce que la gauche
fait de l'obstruction ah bah évidemment
ils l'ont revendiqué madame Rousseau en
l'entendu d'ailleurs la revendiquer
explicitement mais il faut que le les
gens qui ne regardent comprennent parce
que c'est un peu de la technique
parlementaire pourquoi est-ce que c'est
grave parce qu'à la limite on pourrait
très bien parler 3 mois ce serait
pénible pour les parlementaires mais on
pourrait très bien passer trois mois
avoir les amendements de la nupesse si
les y tenaient là le gouvernement a
annoncé et a déposer une un une le 43-1
pardon c'est à dire que le texte va être
regardé en très peu de jours et que s'il
se texte n'est pas regardé n'est pas
étudié dans les délais il partira au
Sénat sans qu'on puisse sans que
l'Assemblée nationale et puis regarder
tous les articles or les mesures les
plus importantes le report de l'âge à 64
ans et l'accélération de la réforme
Touraine avec 43 ans de cotisations sont
dans l'article 7 donc s'il y a trop
d'amendements avant on peut pas arriver
l'article 7 c'est ce qui est arrivé on
l'a vu à la commission des affaires
sociales vous dites vous ne faites pas
d'obstruction vous allez déposé combien
d'amendements
200 amendements mais 200 un moment ils
sont pas tous avant l'article 7 donc on
est la plupart d'ailleurs sont sur
l'article 7 puisque c'est ce qui pose
problème aux Français parce que là ils
se sont arrêtés en commission des
affaires sociales à l'index des seniors
bon on pense que c'est index des seniors
est insuffisant que c'est un gadget mais
il mérite pas comme l'a dit la madame
Rousseau qu'on s'arrête dessus pendant
quatre jours et qu'on bloque le texte
dessus c'est un détail de la réforme ce
qui intéresse les français ce qui met
les gens dans la rue c'est 64 ans et 43
ans de cotisations donc là le la gauche
fait du sabotage sur l'opposition ce qui
nous empêche de voter contre vraiment
que les gens comprennent cette cette
obstruction va empêcher les oppositions
de bloquer le texte alors Jean-Philippe
Tanguy le groupe
[Musique]